قال رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران
خان، إن الديمقراطية
مهددة في بلاده، ويعتقد
أنه لا يوجد حكم قانون الآن، وفي
حديثه مع فريد زكريا على قناة CNN يوم
الأحد، قال أيضًا إنه
متحصن حاليًا في مجمع إقامته في
لاهور و  لا يزال المجمع
محاصرًا من قبل الشرطة الآن، وقد
قال المسؤولون إنهم يريدون اعتقال
الأفراد داخل المجمع لأنهم
يعتقدون أنهم انتهكوا القانون أثناء
الاحتجاجات بعد اعتقال عمران خان في
وقت سابق من هذا الشهر، والآن يرفض خان
ما يقوله عن هؤلاء المؤيدين الذين
كانوا  لا ينبغي أن يحاكم المعتقلون أمام
محكمة عسكرية، وهو ما قال المسؤولون إنهم سيحاكمونه، وهذا
أمر
اتفقت عليه جماعات حقوق الإنسان أيضًا
مع
كل ما يتم القيام به
فقط من أجل تفكيك ديمقراطيتنا، لذا،
في الوقت الحالي، تم اعتقال أكثر من 10000
عامل.
قيادتي العليا بأكملها في السجن،
أنا يوم الثلاثاء، سأظهر
أمام الكفالة المختلفة في
إسلام أباد، هناك 80 احتمالًا أن يتم القبض علي،
لذا لا يوجد حكم قانون في الوقت الحالي.
تم إطاحة عمران خان كرئيس للوزراء
في أبريل من عام 2018.  في العام الماضي، اتهم
قائد الجيش بالتحريض على هذا الأمر
والعمل مع الحكومة الحالية
لإبعاده عن السلطة. الآن هذا
شيء لكن الحكومة
والجيش أنكروا قائلين إن هذه
الاتهامات غير صحيحة الآن وكان خان
حريصًا على عدم انتقاد الجيش.
في حد ذاته قال إنه من المهم أن يكون لديك
جيش قوي وليس لديه
مشكلة مع المؤسسة نفسها لكنه
يشير بإصبع الاتهام إلى
قائد الجيش. ما أعرفه
هو أنه عمل خلال الأشهر الستة الماضية على إزالة
حكومتي وهو زعم علنًا
بعد ذلك في مقابلة أنه
قرر أنني أمثل خطرًا كبيرًا على
البلاد ولذلك تمت
الإطاحة بحكومتي منذ ذلك الحين.
كل ما قلته هو أن حل
مشاكل باكستان
يكمن في انتخابات حرة ونزيهة لأن
هذا هو  الشيء الوحيد الذي من شأنه أن يحقق
الاستقرار السياسي في هذا البلد،
قال خان أيضًا إنه يعتقد أن حياته
في خطر، ويقول إنه كانت هناك
محاولة اغتيال ضده في
نوفمبر من العام الماضي، وقد أصيب في
ذلك الهجوم، وهو يشعر بالقلق من أنه
عندما  إذا ذهب إلى إسلام أباد يوم الثلاثاء،
هناك فرصة جيدة جدًا
لإعادة اعتقاله وبالطبع القلق
بعد ذلك هو هل سيكون هناك المزيد من الاضطرابات
والاحتجاجات. شكرًا لك روح باولا هانكوك على شبكة سي إن إن